[Music]
this game was played between
um a master from from germany georg levy
and black was a guy named akiba
rubinstein
brilliant chess player from the early
20th century unfortunately spent the
latter half of his life
in an asylum as a lot of chess i mean
i don't want to laugh at that but it
seems that it's been
it's been a topic of conversation but
even when he was there he was
contributing a lot to chess
understanding
for the entirety of his life um so this
was
a real chess wizard akiba rubinstein
and he was kind of the founder one of
the founders of positional chess if that
makes sense um he was one of the
you know in his time everybody was
throwing pieces at their opponent
rubenstein was a very calm player but
that that didn't mean he didn't have
brilliancies
and this game was one of them so it
starts out actually with d4
and um rubenstein played d5 and here
white
gave up the game i mean again this this
move was so brilliant it was over
it was over after that i don't think i
need to show you the rest of the game do
i
um no i mean that seems like a pretty
big mic drop
yeah it is it is so we have a queen's
pawn opening
rally plays knight f3 rubenstein plays
e6 just uh reinforcing
the pawn on d5 oops i cannot draw that
arrow
rod levy plays e3 he does the same thing
now what are the drawbacks of both of
these moves like what is the downside of
developing like this
oh yeah blocks your bishop bingo yeah
blocks the bishop which you know
that doesn't mean both of them are
stupid it's just a
way of developing that's a little bit
more conservative so
c5 rubinstein contesting the center
these this is rubenstein of course i
recognize these moves daniel
of course i mean your long-lost freaking
friend rubenstein
um so c4 knight c6 knight c3 knight f6
now you have this little
box in the center box of pawns which
looks very complicated but
really it's not because everything is
defended by everything you see that
this pawn defends this pawn this bishop
defends this one so neither side
wants to flinch but ratliffy does he
takes on c5 he says i'm going to get rid
of this tension
okay rubenstein plays bishop takes c5
and here rod levy plays the move
a3 what do you think he's prepared he's
preparing a certain move what is he
preparing
b4 exactly so rubenstein plays a6
and you'll see the point of this move in
a second after b4 bishop d6
you see that he's discouraging white
from attacking the knight by playing b5
because black is going to take on b5 and
open up the a file
okay do you remember your game against
one uh you rob
do you kind of vaguely remember a trap
that we had talked about beforehand and
you actually won his queen with that
trap
now you got to move over to wrong but
you got the trap correct
rubenstein in his annotations the great
rubenstein
writing in latin and i and i quote
writes
and here i took us the examples from one
charlieus against the irabus
that's great so after c takes d5e takes
d5 knight takes d5
why is white not just getting a free
pawn
uh because we deliver um
don't you dare get the move order wrong
oh
you just gotta give me a minute sure
take your time
so undefended pieces drop off you know
the
theme i think you're just trying to get
the order right is that right yeah i
can't i don't remember it
what okay so so here's the thing first
you take his knight
and then this queen on d5 is a sitting
duck how can you exploit it
you deliver the check on b4 from here
bingo and then you take the queen now
against europe i think you did this
first it was something along that along
those lines now what is the problem with
taking the pawn first just to the topic
of like the order of things
okay yeah yeah because i mean you can
just immediately take the bishop back
right
exactly either with his knight or with
his pawn and all you do is win the pawn
back
so for that reason rob levy goes bishop
b2 fianchettoing his bishop
robinstein castles thanks for the sub mr
bayless and
queen d2 by ron levy so i'm going fast
through the opening because i want to
get to sort of the fun part
um oh sorry my badge so actually raleigh
didn't even take this pawn at all
he he just left it on d5 he goes bishop
uh b2
castles queen d2 i mean they're just
bringing their pieces out is this sort
of making sense thus far
yeah pretty standard stuff queen e7 by
rubenstein connecting his rooks
potentially in bishop d3 by rolody
now take a look at this bishop on c8 can
you develop it much like white's
developed his
except can you do all of that by force
so he doesn't play b6 here
he finds a way to develop the bishop to
b7 by and winning time at the same time
and to like do it all with tempo if that
makes sense
did you start by pushing that pawn to b5
instead
well first you want to do something
before you do that right because here
white's going to take the free pawn
so b5 plays into his line but you need
to do what first
and you can flip the board by the way
we're going to look at this from black's
perspective for the most part so
so you should flip the board okay
so b5 is the second move of the line
what do we have to do first to make sure
white can't take the pawn
we need to bring the bishop to d7
instead
well we're trying to develop the bishop
to b7 oh i see
okay so you're right in thinking that b5
is the right idea
but again it's your resistance to
trading
i feel like that's a thing don't be so
against
taking pawns and pieces in order to get
stuff done
so you just take on c4 then to start
exactly because you go
you lure the bishop here now you play b5
and you attack the bishop
so white has to waste another move
moving the bishop back you see what i'm
saying
bishop b7 now we have basically a
symmetrical position except there's one
small drawback
or sorry i bet he doesn't play bishop b7
yet you see this queen on d2
can we make it uncomfortable
can we make this queen uncomfortable
we can pin the bishop to it absolutely
x-ray uh we can bring yeah we can bring
our rook over to d8
as he did now this is also just a good
move because the rook is occupying an
open file
and you'll see that this was actually a
serious mistake from white putting the
queen on d2
so white wastes another move with queen
e2
and after bishop b7 castles rubinstein
makes another move that perhaps
intuitively you wouldn't like to make
because it offers a trade
i see this bishop on b7 you see how both
of these bishops
are x-raying white's king now the
problem is that this bishop is being
blocked in by black's knight
and the other problem is that white has
this knight on f3 which defends the area
surrounding white's king
can you eliminate both problems with one
move
well before i do that i wanted to ask a
question oh never mind i was going to
say why wouldn't we greek gift sacrifice
it's guarded by the knight
exactly well let's set up that rig of
sacrifice by taking the knight out of
the picture
yeah so we need to move the knight first
here so i'm guessing
he probably moved the knight over to e5
setting up a trade with knight bingo
that's exactly right
knight e5 well white has nothing better
to do than to take the knight bishop
takes e5
and rollaby precisely because he's
trying to avoid ideas like the greek
gift sacrifice
kicks away whites or blacks bishop with
f4
now when you look at this move do you
see any drawbacks that it might contain
any positional
weaknesses like does this move weaken
any pawns perhaps
or open any diagonals like anything you
can tell me here
yeah so a couple things i noticed that
e3 pawn got a lot weaker it doesn't have
any pawns that can protect it and it's
opened up the diagonal here
dark diagonal on the case so how can we
reroute this bishop to exploit that
diagonal where can we go with that
bishop
c7 or well yeah c7 and then bring it up
to b6
exactly so he plays bishop c7 e4
now remember the threat is stronger than
the execution so we don't want to rush
with this move
first we want to improve a piece that's
not doing anything right now we want to
put it on an open file which piece am i
talking about
uh right now our a rook isn't doing
anything but i don't know
uh do we put it on c8 exactly we do and
we kind of x-ray the night
and again i want you to understand that
not every move has to pose a specific
threat sometimes you're just improving
the overall position of your piece it's
not that this rook is going to threaten
the night when the knights frickin
defend it
it's more that every piece is not
harmoniously placed
sorry i was trying to remove the arrow
and draw drew like four new ones
in its place so e5 was played and guess
what rubenstein plays bishop b6 check
now look at these freaking snappers so
in this position
the fun begins the game lasts only five
more moves but these five moves
are absolutely stunning every one of
them better than the previous one
so okay black's knight is being attacked
correct rupert stein found a very
creative square for this night rather
than just meekly dropping it back
what rumenstein noticed is that white
has a lot of undefended pieces here are
pieces that are very flimsily defended
you see this knight on c3 is only
defended by the bishop and you see this
bishop on d3 right
it's only defended by the queen and if
we can eliminate this bishop
then this bishop on b7 is going to be
completely uncontested along the long
diagonal
so rubenstein finds a way to explain all
of that and put the knight on a massive
square
i i think i know it squares does he
bring it to g4 he absolutely [ __ ]
does bring it to g4 and if white takes
that knight
you can can you see how bad this is for
white yeah
i mean everything is hanging rook t2 is
a threat white's going to get demolished
here so
rob levy says no no no no i'm not
letting you run freaking circles over me
he plays bishop e4
and he says i'm taking this piece of
[ __ ] out of out of the equation
but now rubenstein finds a way to
combine this knight on g4
with another very strong piece does
anything come to mind
and think about this it's not a
necessarily a simple move to see
but it's a very strong one
does he bring the knight to e3
good move that would be a good move but
i'm going to give you a hint he doesn't
move the knight
the knight on g4 is actually very strong
but it needs to be combined with another
piece
yeah so he just brings up the pawn to f5
then no because it gets unpassanted he
can't do that yep bingo so
it's actually not the pawn it's another
piece and we don't just want to defend
the knight we want to create a threat
while we're doing it
yeah so he brings the queen over to h4
bingo
now white obviously can't take on b7
because of checkmate
right but it seems like it might seem
that rubenstein is actually blundered
because
white plays g3 and here's the thing we
open up the defense of the h2 square we
attack the queen and we're attacking the
bishop
now black certainly doesn't want to
simplify the position right because
simplification is good for white
then white's king becomes safer and now
rubenstein played an
absolutely stunning move now i'm going
to guide you through the thinking
process behind this move and i want you
to try to find the move
so here's here's what rubenstein know i
don't i didn't [ __ ] talk to him but i
think this is what he noticed
um when i say this is what he know like
okay i don't literally what he noticed
now look at the bishops imagine a
hypothetical scenario
where white is lacking both his queen
and his knight imagine that they're gone
what would you do in that position
well if the queen wasn't there you just
go in there for a checkmate there right
but
but but i want i want you to
specifically tie this into black's
bishops
if the knight weren't there and the
queen weren't there what would we do
you'd take that bishop on e4 and what
would that be
that would be checkmate well with the
exception of some [ __ ] rook after
remove that would be checkmate
so the thing is when you come up with an
idea like this a lot of people will say
well that's not possible right because
my queen is being attacked i have to
attend to the queen
but what rubenstein says is i don't
always have to attend to my queen some
ideas are so important that you can
sacrifice not only a queen
but even more than a queen over them and
so he tries to make this happen
literally if you had the task of getting
rid of two of these pieces
what would you start with i'd start with
rook d3
actually he can't take with bishop it'd
have to be a queen take
okay but very you're very close
but here i would take the queen and we
haven't made any progress as far as
eliminating
those pieces goes we have to actually
make progress but you have the right
idea he uses this idea on the 23rd move
but now we have something that we can do
immediately
we can take one of those pieces out
immediately
one of the troublesome pieces so we just
take that night out well no we don't
take the night out because then he just
takes the queen well that doesn't
consider that that's what rubenstein
does
reuben's role if he takes the queen he's
like what the [ __ ] you doing man
and now rubenstein plays another
stunning move notice the relationship
we've seen this today in several puzzles
the relationship between the queen and
the bishop
can you distract this queen from its
defense of this bishop
by using another one of your pieces
yeah um and he sacrifices literally he
sets the board on fire with this next
move if you don't like this next move
you don't like chess
i'm talking to the chat of course i know
you do
you know me and i love rubenstein of
course of course you were
telling me about rubenstein i had to
tell you to shut up you were talking so
much about rubens i was waking up you
were talking about rubenstein going to
sleep you were talking about rubenstein
jesus yeah i couldn't help it there he
he brings the rook to d2
instead of three right he brings it to
d2 that's a distraction sacrifice notice
that both rooks are hanging
and let's unpack this position for a
second if white takes this rook
well then black can actually just take
black and take the queen and mate but
taking the bishop is actually forced
mate
because if queen takes e4 what does
black do
does he take pawn on h2 check uh
brings queen over nah
what can you tell me about this
oh no that's still check that's sorry
that's still checkmate right yeah it is
it is because the bishop on b6 notice
how harmoniously all the black pieces
are placed each piece fulfilling
a very specific role so for that reason
rotli says okay i'm taking this rook on
d2
and it appears that rubenstein is
blundered because
this this is not meth now this is not
checkmate why
he blocks with the rook well if he
blocks with a rook we'll take the rock
but he can actually block with something
else
what what else can oh he slides the
queen over to g slides
here's the problem we might say great i
take eyewitness queen but remember we
sacrificed the queen
this is not satisfactory what's the
material count here
he's up right now he's up in exchange
and we don't [ __ ] want that after all
these sacrifices
rubenstein made a move after which white
resigned yeah i was gonna say
that right there then you fork on e3 and
you yes
but your his rook your work is also
still hanging and let me point something
out even if you were to win a rook
the material would be equal and after
all that fanfare to get it just an end
game wouldn't you agree that that's a
little disappointing
yeah i mean rubenstein makes what to me
is my favorite move of this whole
combination
because it's not a check it's a quiet
move that wins the game
immediately and i want you to i'm not
going to set it up for you i want you to
take your time and try to
try to try to win this the hint is that
white resigned after this move
like this was so strong white gave up
immediately up a queen and an exchange
does he uh so the first thing i looked
at and i don't know if this is right
because i haven't finished calculating
it but it seems like a kind of cool move
is he slides his rook over to h3 that
gives the queen
multiple attackers but all of which you
can still get a made off of right
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you got it i had to
get it that's it
that's it h3 using the pin
and if queen takes e4 remind me of the
move
now i'm just taking on a on h2 checkmate
there is nothing that white can do about
this he could play rook f3
but you would simply take the rook and
then it's checkmate he could play bishop
d4 you would take the bishop
and this would be a lot less beautiful
than just resigning the game
i love positions where somebody resigns
like up a queen so rook h3
another possibility here would be to go
rook c2 with the same idea
um but rook h3 is infinitely more
beautiful
so this is that later did he do the c2
he played rook at rubenstein well what
do you think
are you not putting your faith in
rumenstein my friend do i know
okay thanks yeah that was a bit
ridiculous how could you ever rubenstein
never made mistakes rook h3 is what
happened in the game and rob will be
resigned so just to recap this whole
combination
it starts with knight g4 white tries to
throw water onto the
fire with bishop b4 you play queen h4
involving the queen
now he comes up with a scenario where
the queen and the queen and the
knight are gone so he takes out the
knight sacking the queen
takes out the queen sacking the rook and
after this
we dismantle the queen using the rest of
our pieces the bishop on b6
is actually the unsung hero of the whole
combination what i want you to notice
is that this move f4 lost white the game
it might not seem significant
but that is the importance of positional
weaknesses when you weaken your position
and you create a long-term weakness
sometimes you don't even realize to what
degree you're hurting yourself
yeah would that be something you'd
consider in this position like would you
think of f4 as a bad move here if you
were playing this game
well white's already in some trouble
because otherwise as you pointed out
black has various ideas related to the
greek gift sacrifice but i
when i look at this move i immediately
see how bad it is to weaken this pawn
now i'm not going to pretend that
everything else was like white had other
chances to survive in this game
but i hate making long-term weaknesses
and what i also want you to understand
is moves like rook aca you should start
playing
first of all you're you know sometimes
you have to trade
if that's what the position demands
second of all some moves are just
general improving moves
okay maintenance moves we talked about
that
not every move has to create a threat
some moves just bring the piece into the
game
and in your games i want you to try
doing more of that sometimes the reason
you're slow
and you hesitate is because there comes
a moment when
you don't quite see how to attack again
i don't want to put words in your mouth
but when that moment arises just ask
yourself what is my worst place peace
can i improve that peace what are my
opponent's pawn weaknesses
can i pile up on those pawn weaknesses
you know what i'm saying
yeah okay so hopefully you enjoyed this
game and
hopefully it'll set us up for a finale
in which you kick some butt
what do you say to that that sounds good
man can you bring us back two moves
though
before f4 was played absolutely so what
is the optimal play here just bringing
the pawn up to f3 instead to take away
the greek gift sacrifice thing yeah i
would say h3 actually to take away the
greek of sacrifice because
because this covers the g4 square
actually the greek gift
itself is not so much threatened like if
white goes rooks you won
you take on h2 and here instead of going
knight she four chuck because the square
is covered you can win back the piece
with what move
win back what we just lost yeah we can
win back the bishop and we
will have an extra pawn again take a
very close look at white's undefended
pieces
uh is it taking that bishop there on d3
and then
the queen takes oh [ __ ] then you want to
deliver the check on d4
yeah that's what i was that is actually
really nice
um that actually is really really cool
uh i might go king g3 here so it might
not be entirely clear-cut and after
queen g5 now i play f4 and i try to
chase her queen away but
i first of all big time points for
finding that move oh 95 here should win
the game
95 here wins because you set up the move
queen g5 with devastating consequences
beautiful i actually didn't notice that
either so queen d6 check was what i was
thinking and then you take the bishop
that's like the more vanilla option
i get you i guess i was looking for in
the spirit of rupenstein looking for
more
that's [ __ ] awesome so i think that
that works
um oh and one thing and i think we
talked about it a while ago that if you
do this
can you remind me of the next move
for the greek gift now we're sliding the
queen over to h4 now white has this
defensive resource where he plays queen
to
d6 covering that square but black is
still winning
with what move another one of those
quiet moves
you just push that pawn to e5 right
bingo and you win either the queen or
you deliver checkmate
yeah exactly nice so
for that reason i would have played
instead of f4
oh that was a bit of a long answer to
your question but i would have played h3
so that
there's just no sacrifice and you know
white can survive here black is better
black black has the initiative but white
white is solid here i mean the game goes
on
that makes sense okay yeah it all makes
sense to me
fantastic so what do you say you hop
back into the pool for one or two more
games
sounds good to me man yeah i'll get back
to 1k tonight that [ __ ] tilt is rough
oh i trust you're talking to the [ __ ]
king of tilt
so i'm not sure i could a lot of people
ask how do you avoid till well
not sure i'm the authority on that
matter of course hylian trafftruff
damn you're playing some intimidating
guys here h6
interesting yeah i cut off the uh fried
liver
okay that's that's a move now he's got
d4 he's gone sort of for a version of
the scotch
but i still just take here right take
take now instead of h6 you could also
play bishop out to c5
develop is that stronger than h6 yeah
because h6 is not developing a piece but
here you could play as you did against
one xqc
remember you put the bishop on c5 yeah
okay and uh
yeah yeah and if he plays c3
well you could play queen f6 and well
actually
do you remember what i taught you in
this position
yeah right now i'm looking at going to
f6 right yeah
and reliving the glory days reliving the
glories
i can't i can't believe it he just lost
but that was still such a powerful
moment in my career there
indeed indeed smarter thanks for the
five gifted okay so he's castled but now
remember
yeah queen takes c6 then you want to
develop your knight in castle
thanks for the five gifted man really
appreciate it smarter all the support is
awesome you guys
loving the hype thanks alright
so he's thinking about what to do here
you've got a nice solid position
now here you want to be careful about
where you put your knight if you put
your knight on f6
you walk into a very unpleasant move
here do you see what i'm talking about
does he just push the pawn up to e5
actually you have a tactic here
look at his bishop on c4 what can you
tell me about it
well right now it's just totally
undefended it's undefended it's a
sitting duck
so what discovered attack do you have
yeah and perfect so that's the danger of
taking with c6 nicely done
okay now one thing i want you to
remember you did this sometimes in park
champs one once you win a pawn or a
piece
you don't want to then abandon your
development you want to keep developing
okay because otherwise you might all of
a sudden give your opponent let's say an
initiative
so now when it comes to developing the
knight i don't really want the knight on
f6 anyway right so for the queen i just
want to drop the queen back to
how about a forcing move no don't let
him develop a tempo
so what comes to mind sorry to cut you
off
no all good um well i have to i have to
move queen or
look for a check but i just don't see it
check that there
there is a check oh okay i can yeah i
can just deliver this one right here
on c5 yeah yeah absolutely and if he
drops this king back to f1 you actually
have a beautiful move there
look at your bishop on c8 assuming he
plays king f1 which i think he might
where would that bishop then belong you
have a square for that bishop that could
potentially be absolutely devastating
right there at a6 bingo so what would
you do i'd look to push this b
pawn and bring it over that's like the
fianchetto on steroids developing the
bishop to a6
my guess is he's going to play king f1 i
don't oh yeah he is yeah
so now i'm just going to do this just
like we talked about exactly and the
great thing is
to what we just looked at a little bit
it is it is the bishop and the queen
mike
he guesses what he wants to do is move
his knight out so he
really wants to play knight b3 or knight
f3
and he doesn't know what's gonna hit him
i mean it's like a runaway train
bishop a6 and he's going to lose a bunch
of pieces there
so he actually he doesn't have a great
way of stopping bishop a6
if he plays queen e2 here you have a way
to reinforce the threat of bishop basics
involving that rook on a8 do you see how
he does do you see how to reinforce that
threat
yeah i'm just going to push the a pawn
to a5 and then bring the bishop over
right
got it yep now the thing is
once you play bishop a6 he's going to
play c4
but that creates this tension where his
queen and his knight are going to be
tied down to that pawn
and you can use that to open up more
files like you can basically freeze them
in place
welcome coach peter
yeah so he's he's in big trouble here
now there are ways he can get out of
this situation but
i don't know if hailey and trafftrav
well okay now what to do
hmm well i have to move queen here well
i mean i could attack
his queen but that was just two pieces
right you don't want to really trade
here now
notice that after bishop a6 he has the
possibility of intercepting
uh the diagonal with c4 could you put
your queen on a square
where it keeps c4 under control so that
bishop a6 becomes a threat
do i just drop the queen back to keep c4
occupy yeah exactly well c to c6 right
so that c4 is under control
the c6 yeah just making sure you didn't
mean queen c4
no no yeah no i just meant like keeping
c4 occupied as in like
watching it making sure it's like safe
yep
that's exactly right
so but you know what he should do here
is move his king to g1
and get rid of him but it's not a move
that a lot of like beginner type players
like to
make because it doesn't seem like it
accomplishes anything
but um he's got no other good way of
stopping that move
this b685 idea is pretty darn advanced i
like it
okay so he does this
do i want to deliver the check with the
bishop here or
i would hold off on that now here's the
thing what is he threatening
uh right now he's looking at this weak
g7
upon here looks like it looks like if
you give that pawn up that'll be
devastating for you but
there is a hidden benefit that you get
from him taking on g7 if you can
correctly position your pieces what do
you gain from that
in the context of attacking his king
um he relinquishes any defense on the
light tiles
and what other file does he open up for
you
he opens up the g file so could you set
up a situation where once he takes on g7
you bring your rook to g8 and attack its
queen and occupy that file which might
potentially be
huge for it you
i was just going to say is it just the
standard development going right to f6
then
okay that's exactly right and you're
sacrificing two pawns here that's a
pretty big price to pay but
that g file as you can probably tell is
going to be huge
right it's going to be huge it's going
to be tremendous
and my guess is he's going to take the
pawn because like once you played queen
g4
you can't exactly shy away from that
yeah so now i'm just going immediately
g8 protected by knight i'd lose the h6
pawn
totally fine but that even opens up the
h file for you so it's a good thing to
stack all these funds now you want to
complete your development by force
this is where it's a good idea to play
that move you wanted to play for a while
which is what the uh the a6
bingo and then you've gotta take care of
your king
is there a way to do that yeah i'm just
gonna
castle along yep and then you can start
generating plants now in terms of that
open g
file once you castle are there any plans
that you can come up with to exploit
that file
and it's a typical idea you like this
plan yeah it's just standard stacking
rooks
right all about the [ __ ] stacking so
where would the rook on g8 go in order
to stack as efficiently as possible
g6 exactly now notice also
for the future if he ever pushes this e
pawn out to e5
first of all there's gonna be checkmate
on g2 second of all
um well he goes for sure g5 so he
literally
forces you to make the correct move
of just bringing the rook out yeah yeah
yeah and notice that once you stack his
bishop on g5
is going to be hanging he's going to
have to move that bishop and then you're
going to take on g2
with potentially devastating effect
there's actually some rubinstein-esque
ideas there this might be
a beautiful win if you play this right
he's probably going to play queen h4
that's essentially his only move
yeah but i'm still stacking that doesn't
change the idea
now my guess is he's gonna think he's
smart and take your knight
but are you taking back that knight or
do you have your eyes on a greater prize
you mean taking back the bishop yeah do
you take back the bishop or do you have
a better move in mind
well i just immediately slide the rook
up there and take off right
and while it's not checkmate yet it's
going to be very close to checkmate so
you absolutely want to trust that you're
going to have checkmate there
do it yeah
okay so whoa there is some really cool
[ __ ] going on here
there is like an ultimate five-head move
here
um there's actually a couple really cool
ideas
so what comes to mind for you here
um
so let me guide your thinking you see
this pawn on e4
if you could eliminate that pawn that
would pave open that huge
long diagonal now the problem is this
pawn is defended by first and foremost
the queen
could you slice off the connection
between his queen and his pawn
yeah i just bring up well i don't bring
up my g8 rook i bring down my
exactly so as not to allow that check on
b8 to happen
right so we go rook she four and once
that pawn is captured
there's gonna be hell to pay so
you see that sometimes you want to play
simple you don't want to sack queens you
just want to
you know meat and potatoes kind of move
those can be the strongest moves in many
positions
you know sliding his queen down to h7
doesn't well i just take his queen
what does he do there what was his idea
of this move
well it's attacking my queen okay so
do you want to take their queen
immediately or do you want to maybe
first make some preliminary move
okay so that was actually a really
strong move he found okay so i need to
attend to this pressure here with my
queen being in this position
now where would you slide your queen in
order to keep contact
potentially with that pawn on e4 there's
a
amazing move here keep contact with that
pawn so you need to keep the queen on
the same diagonal
but move the queen out to such a square
such that the bishop can then come to b7
and stack up with the queen it's a
really strong move
so we just have to go all the way back
to a8 yeah exactly
now look at the queen operating from a
long range you don't need to keep the
queen close to the attack
it's just as good if not better from a8
as it is from like
f2 so
he's actually defending super well here
uh but you're still attacking
let's see what he ends up doing here
okay
so he's probably going to move his
screen somewhere to try to defend that
e4
what do you think he's going to do i was
looking at h7 for that queen
okay that would have been correct
i i don't really see what that position
does for him is it something i'm missing
is that just not a great move not a
great move
i'm still bringing the bishop to b7 well
but you don't even have to do
well you can but you don't even have to
do that you can just go ahead and
immediately
do what just take it with the ropes yeah
take it with a rook open up the diagonal
and then later you're going to bring the
bishop to b7 but right now you don't
need to do that
you see what i'm saying i would pre-move
i would pre-move queen takes c4 just to
save a little bit of time
now he's probably going to block with
his queen and think that he's defended
but there you have a beautiful move
look at his king his king is out of
squares okay now look at that knight on
f3
you want to be very careful about how
you attack that knight
because if you play bishop b7 what move
does he have
if i go bishop b7 yeah what move does he
have then
i don't really see what that would
relinquish because
well dude oh does he bring it over to f1
yeah so you can attack the knight in
such a way that he doesn't have rook f1
do you see a square
yeah i just bring the bishop over to e2
then yeah indeed
indeed indeed that's exactly what you're
okay
okay now if this guy was real fivefed he
would play rook f1 anyway that's not
really a thousand level move
but i mean otherwise you basically
checkmate him
so let's see whether he does that
now after he plays rook f1 let's imagine
that he does that
you don't even have to rush taking his
rook because he's paralyzed
now could you then find a way to
maneuver your rook onto such a square
that it attacked where it attacks the
knight
yeah i'm just going to do a little a
little rook lift right so i'd bring it
over to g6 and then i'd take bishop and
have it attack the knight
right but but the problem with rook g6
is that he he's going to move his bishop
back
so could you lift the rook onto a square
where it's not
that the square's not defended wow this
guy is
really good the right one is g4 bingo
bingo and then f4 and he still has a
defense here if he finds this move well
i don't know i'm gonna just start being
i mean he's got to stop the move rook f4
with what move
it's the only way to stop brooke iv he's
got to move the bishop right he's got to
bring bishop over to
e5 exactly and then
well you could always take his rook okay
well he misses it he kind of sends you
towards
that squad yeah he didn't find it so i'm
just still going f4 and that's going to
be game right
yeah really a lot he can do here yeah
you're just going to take everything
here yeah
i'm going to take all of his pieces
what was the defense bishop e5
using the bishop after that i meant
oh like what would what would have been
your move after bishop e5
yeah yeah sorry you would have probably
like gone d6 and chased that bishop away
you're still like
i mean the attack is still devastating
he's paralyzed so you would have just
slowly
maybe after the game i'll show you what
the methods would be in that position
but you would have to exercise some like
deep calculation and good attacking
technique
okay so what comes to mind here
how do you i was going to say with
bishop right
because it's chuck he can't take my
queen with rook
right but then he waves his king now
think about taking the knight with a
rook what happens if you take the knight
with your rock
there's no check but i am attacking the
queen and you're preparing a discover
check which is going to be totally
devastating
yeah you want to prepare the discover
check that's going to be the strongest
device in these positions
so if he takes on e2 with the rook
trying to counter-attack your queen you
have a check made in two moves that
involves a double check
yeah it's bringing the rook to h3 right
bingo
exactly and then
after that the checkmate is sliding it
okay yeah
then quinn that's it well okay so has he
stopped you from doing that
no i still just take on h3 because he
can't take with queen it's pin
using the pen now you're gonna use the
pin again here shortly to win the game
he's going to bring his king to g1
do you see any other good checks in that
position
any other check scour the board for
checks
yeah the best check i see here i think
is going to
e three nice yeah nice gotta block with
his queen
right and remember something we talked
about during the puzzle when the king
defends a piece
that's a very flimsy defensive mechanism
you can separate the two very easily by
giving a check to the king
now which am i talking about i delivered
the check with the rook at g3
bingo king has to move because because
of the pin and then you take the queen
you can even pre-move
queen takes f2 if you want i
i won't get too wild here
exactly no you can make them without
taking the queen but that's not
necessary
that was a pretty wild game it was i
mean
i think that like finding bishop takes
f2 is crucial and he defended
tremendously well
like i honestly when you when you sacked
the knight and played rook takes g2 i
expected
um the attack to just like go very
quickly but he actually found a bunch of
very nice defensive resources
that was a good game oh i brought him
down to 999 as well poor guy
man's punching air oh yeah you brought
him below a thousand
you brought him below a thousand that
always a [ __ ] dagger when that
happens man
it did indeed